now in the face of a tragedy like this
there's only so much you can learn from
numbers but it's worth just looking back
at some of the context you know how does
this situation compare in terms of
migrant crossings with previous years
how does it compare with other countries
and here's the picture compared over
time so we're just looking here at
cumulative channel crossings and the
higher these lines are the more
crossings there are over the course of
each year that's 2018 you can see 2019
just there 2020 you can see the line
getting higher but look at 2021 that
line considerably higher up now uh to 25
792 so almost 26 000 of course it's
climbing uh more or less every day that
is the highest that we've seen in any
data series we have uh going back as far
as we have but it's worth just comparing
the uk with other countries around the
world we've seen those pictures of
course in spain and italy and greece uh
of many people crossing into those
countries so how does the uk compare how
does that 25
792 compared with greece well it's above
greece uh you can see this year this is
just this year so far greece 3500 or so
uh spain 36 000 so more uh than the uk
so far and in italy actually more than
double uh what we've seen thus far uh in
the uk um but of course it's worth also
just looking back in time so over time
you know the uk has been going up a bit
but compare that with these other
countries where has been much higher in
fact i'm just going to kind of change
the axis here so you can see look that's
greece there
and back in 2015 you were talking about
getting towards a million a year so
nearly a million a year much higher than
what we're seeing at the moment in the
uk but nonetheless pretty unprecedented
uh in the uk but looking overall at the
picture for asylum seekers asylum
applications actually the uk this is
compared with other countries in europe
the uk relatively low when you compare
it to head of the population when it
comes to overall asylum applications but
still when you're looking at channel
crossings we have really never seen a
year quite like this